et ceux qui se promènent dans la vie
comme dans les rayons d'un supermarché
et ceux qui ne voient de paris que les
vitrines ans
m
juste pourquoi est ce qu'ils doivent
faire
je vais
ça
petit quai d'orsay
à 5 ans
[Musique]
j'étais là
qu'aurais tu sais
entremont bien
non
[Musique]
shatner rêve
allez
[Applaudissements]
attendant ce jour est excitant bas
j'aime les gens
ils vont voir un grand mère
cyril est un jeu en vaut la peine
via ce qui incombe en
[Musique]
ceux qui abusent jamais je ne sais
il traverse compagnie
qu'on ait à cette lie nos prêts
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu